au delà ce sommet a aussi pour objet de
discuter de l'organisation et de la
gestion d'internet en l'ignorent souvent
mais les dizaines de millions de sites
les milliards de messages quotidiens le
réseau tout entier est piloté supervisé
par une petite société installée aux
etats-unis sous le contrôle de l'état
américain
explication laurent dit christian le
haut dans le maquis d'internet ce
serveur a une place particulière c'est
celui de l'afnic l'organisme qui a la
charge d'attribuer les noms de domaine
en point fr à chaque demande d'une
adresse finissant par point fr ce sont
donc ces machines qui vous dirige vers
le site internet demandé mais le pouvoir
absolu est détenu par un autre organisme
l'icann qui coordonne l'ensemble des
noms de domaine et qui pourrait d'un
trait plus m'effacer lepoint fr vous les
sites internet en point fr deviendrait
progressivement impossible la visite de
la même manière toutes les adresses
courriel au point fr ça sera de fonction
des tailles cette société est américaine
elle se trouve en californie près de la
silicon valley le berceau historique
d'internet
cette entreprise à but non lucratif a
délégué les noms domaine des pays mais
elles gardent jalousement les points
comme réservé aux commerces point org
pour les institutions et cetera et
cetera
elle peut même créer de nouveaux noms de
domaine problème cette société n'est pas
indépendante qui est vrai c'est que
cannes est une société de droit
américain et que les décisions de
l'icann sont soumises au veto du
département du commerce américain
donc en calories gouvernement américain
peut dire je suis pas d'accord avec une
décision de l'icann elle ne s'appliquera
pas et ça aucun autre gouvernement ne
peut le faire mais si en théorie le
département du commerce américain pour
l'instant n'a encore jamais utilisé son
veto
la prédominance américaine fait
néanmoins tous et les autres pays ces
jours-ci ils ont tout de même obtenu un
lot de consolation au sommet tunis sur
l'information
un forum international pour discuter
d'internet sera mise en place
pas de quoi remettre véritablement en
cause la suprématie américaine à propos
de techno